good day
um my name is dennis allison i'm hosting
uh ee 380
the stanford computer systems
colloquium today's speakers are
damon mccoy and laura edelson they're at
nyu where they're doing
work in well the internet
and all the things that come along with
it um in any case uh
you're on um you know i
very interested in hearing what you've
been doing and how the how the work has
been proceeding
hi dennis great to meet you my name is
laura edelson
um my name is dan mccoy oh yes there he
is
and i'm just going to share my screen
okay so i'd like to talk to you today
about
user trust attacks in digital political
advertising
but first just want to introduce who we
are and why we work in this area so
damon and i work in the nyu
cybersecurity lab we are an
interdisciplinary center
focused on researching technical and
other means just
to secure the cyber infrastructure and
to shape public discourse on the policy
and legal aspects of cyber security
so we've been studying
some of the problems around information
attacks
and user trust attacks in digital
political advertising
since 2018 and we've published
at least some preliminary results
looking
at the security of facebook's
ad library for ads on social issues
elections and politics
as well as some overviews of the
three major transparency archives from
facebook
google and twitter so
what i'd like to talk to you today are
just about what user
trust attacks in digital political
advertising look like
how they've been evolving and what some
potential solutions might be
so let's just start by answering the
question of what a user trust attack
in digital political advertising
actually is
so we think it has a few hallmarks
these attacks exploit users trust in
their social networks and institutions
they promote false beliefs
they often seek to motivate a specific
action or an action on the part of the
user
and they are usually narrowly targeted
to users who would be most susceptible
to the network of trust being exploited
and to evade detection by watchdogs
and users not part of that trust network
so let's take these points in turn so
first exploiting user trust in existing
social networks and institutions
so advertisers do this in
several ways advertisers might pretend
to share a
metric of identity with the user they
might
pretend to share a geographic location
uh
to pretend that they're a neighbor
basically they might pretend
to be part of a trusted institution like
a local newspaper
and occasionally advertisers simply
exploit users trusts in the offices that
that advertiser might hold
so this is an example of advertisers
explaining trust
in metrics of identity
so these are ads that ran in 2018
um the new american media group was
and was a political consultancy that set
up
facebook groups and pages around
different metrics of identity
so these three melanin was aimed at
african americans raising tomorrow was
aimed at young parents
the soldiers network was aimed at
veterans they
then uh promoted political content out
to all of these networks that had
initially been set up
as these sort of apolitical groups
this is an example of uh geographic
targeting
so in this case this was a network of
um sort of these were pages that were
set up to look like they were local news
outlets they were set up across five
swing states or at least swing states in
and they again they promoted sort of
centralized political content
out to all of these local pages
um this is this is uh
another local news approach
this one is less uh news and more local
so where the last one they were really
pretending to be local news outlets
these were just focused around these
pages
um which was set up by a political
consultant in 2020
i believe they set up about 13 of these
pages that were
you know local metro area or local state
proud
and again promoted all this political
content intermingled with
content that was specific to that
geographic area
although this one doesn't have quite
that news focus
okay so um the next part
that we look for is the promotion of
false beliefs
so what do we mean by promoting false
beliefs
because i think very often this is this
is often
lumped in with misinformation and
sometimes it is
it's misinformation that's that's you
know very simple
information is just factually incorrect
but very often
we find content that may not make a
explicitly false statement
but it promotes false beliefs in other
ways so we see a lot
of content that is uh just asking the
question
and also content that has threatening
but non-specific claims and something i
want to call out about one about to show
you
is sometimes the false beliefs that are
being promoted are really only
tangential to the advertiser goal
and it can be a mistake to advertise to
to conflate the message being promoted
with the advertiser's goal
so let's take a look through some of the
things we've seen
so here are some ads that promote the
false belief
that mail-in voting is just rife with
fraud so
protect my vote on the left these ads
are actually aimed at
african american users in um
midwestern swing states chicks on the
right this one is aimed at conservatives
here are some ads promoting the false
belief that
leftist mobs are wreaking
violence on the suburbs so the one in
the upper left is actually from
a uh candidate for congress
he was in this video he will tell you
that there are looting hordes coming
into the georgia suburbs from atlanta
um this middle this uh middle art
ad is doing a good job of just asking
the question
whether catastrophic mass fires are
being deliberately set
by biden voter fire bugs and in the
on the on the right hand side you know
again we're just asking the question
if the left will violently respond if
amy coney barrett is appointed to the
supreme court
so lastly i've got an example of
what is fairly straightforward false
information
so these ads promote the uh the false
idea
that joe biden uh has a policy position
on banning fracking
um and this is sort of an interesting
example of
of again exploiting user trust in their
social networks because while the
advertiser
america first action is a pac they
are making these statements through the
mouth of
um you know sean a union man and
democrat and
brian a third generation oil and gas man
so moving on um
while we often talk about these kinds of
user trust attacks
through a lens that is explicitly
related to an election
and and it certainly is used often to
motivate users to
uh to not vote or to vote uh actually
when we when we look at these kinds of
attacks more generally
we see a lot of ads that are
commercially motivated
so sometimes this commercial motivation
is a little hard to show very explicitly
because
it's tied to for example political
commentators who
make really outlandish uh and
false attacks um and their goal is to
increase their own viewership and
subscriber base that's certainly one way
that um
that some of these attacks are
commercially motivated but actually
there's a lot
that have a very very clear-cut
commercial path
so just to show you a few of these this
was the these are the ads from the uh
page stop mandatory vaccination that are
spreading the false belief that
measles vaccines are dangerous
um what they really want to get you to
do is to buy their
new their nutraceuticals and their books
about
vaccine harm
here's some ads about trumpcare for
america
these are actually selling these
they're not they're not actually legally
health insurance they are
health plans these are actually under
federal investigation right now this
company
here's another one tax blueprint these
are promoting the
false belief that uh you know a wave of
foreclosures is coming due to the
coronavirus
and what they're actually selling is um
this get-rich-quick scheme
so you know we also you know we see this
tactic being pretty widely used
and in general it's usually not that
hard to find a very specific
action that they are that these
advertisers are trying to motivate
so getting on to the last hallmark
that these user trust attacks do need to
be carefully targeted in order to be
effective
so i'm going to talk a little bit more
about
how our project gets at targeting data
but just to give you an example of this
um
donald trump ran an ad that promoted the
false belief that uh joe biden was going
to defund 9-1-1
this ad was or in this this ad in this
claim
do you have a false fact check but
because facebook allows candidates to
run ads with false information this ad
was not removed
but we can see that this ad was targeted
specifically to it was specifically
targeted to
suburban married women so in this case
this ad was shown to
um you know to women in maine and we
have other instances of this ad
shown in other suburbs but basically
always to
married women
so a big part of why this ad targeting
is so important
is that ads that are shown
outside of the trust network that they
are
trying to exploit have so much less
credibility
it's just much easier to um
you know to see through an ad when it
isn't exploiting
your uh community and also
we do know that um watchdogs
need to be able to get at all of these
ads that contain falsehoods
in order to debunk them and warn their
communities about them
so that's what
we see user trust attacks looking like
right now
but i wanted to talk just briefly about
how these attacks have evolved and where
we
you know where we sort of think we've
gotten to at this point
and then we'll start to talk about
solutions
so i just wanted to quickly show you
what i'm sure you're familiar with but
here's some russian disinformation that
ran on facebook
during the 2016 election so here's an
ad promoting
this idea that bernie sanders uh
one with help from arab and muslim
americans
um here's a you know sort of an
anti-hillary clinton ad here's an ad
um promoting you know supporting the
this was part of the back the blue
movement
uh this is an ad uh organizing a protest
against donald trump for
the african-american community here's
another one
promoting this conspiracy theory that uh
bill clinton had an out of wedlock
love child um here's another one
for support for supporters of the second
amendment
here's one for the uh promoting the
african-american community
and what i really want to point out here
is all of these ads in one way or
another
are aimed at users within a specific
trust network some of these are aimed at
americans
like this ad for the um you know
promoting the bill clinton conspiracy
theory
that was aimed very specifically at
african-american
uh users some of these other ads
promoting the
the back the blue and the defend the
second amendment ads
those were aimed at um you know
rural working-class whites
so there's a real range of networks and
a range of messaging
because again the messaging is very
often not the goal
so um just looking and just to give a
very brief over
overview of what we've seen over the
past four years
in 2016 you know i just showed you some
examples of the
russian ira polarization campaigns i'm
sure everyone is also familiar with
the you know the fake news campaigns
that we saw in 2016.
so i think the first thing that took
hold
domestically within the united states
were some of those fake news attacks
so we did see some of that taking place
in 2018
but it did tend to be focused on
specific candidates
where there was an attempt to smear
specific
usually congressional candidates with
fake news
it didn't seem to work too well but it
was absolutely tried again
in several elections in 2019
we have really good documentation of
what happened in the eu election 2019 of
these kinds of
fake news campaigns certainly took place
in several other countries as well
uh that we don't have quite as good
documentation of like australia
and um malaysia but
what we've been seeing in 2020 is
really widespread engagement by u.s
domestic
political actors a little bit in that
fake news
category of attack but what we are
really seeing is
many many advertisers embracing this
idea
of strongly polarizing political
campaigns
via these tools of you know taking on a
mantle
of um of user trust
via one of these methods i've described
and also promoting false beliefs that
are
maybe not tied to a specific fact
pattern of a particular candidate
but maybe more amorphous around these
kinds of ideas around
leftist mobs or you know widespread
mail and bailout fraud or the ones we're
seeing
so um just a couple of points i wanted
to
make about you know about how these
attacks have evolved
um first is that online platforms are
certainly a megaphone
for these kinds of attacks but they're
not the source of the problem
the source of the problem is often you
know an offline
there's some kind of offline source and
the
um these attacks when they are are
pushed out on these digital platforms
are usually part of a multi-pronged
multi-platform attack
for example in 2016 the
uh you know the russian ira efforts on
facebook would not have been nearly as
effective
if they were not done in concert with a
hack and dump of
you know democratic emails that were
then leaked to the media through a
variety of sources
it was a you know it was a broad attack
that was able to polarize because
um it was multi-pronged um but
online platforms do amplify some
messages more than others
they uh the algorithms that promote
content on
many of these uh you know online
platforms
tend to promote the most engaging
content and
what we have found is that when it comes
to politics
more impolarizing more enraging content
is also more engaging
and that's a problem so getting to
solutions
and for this i'm going to hand off to
damon mccoy
who will talk us through some of the
solutions that we're
finding some promise with and some that
we're still exploring
so yeah so i'm going to talk about some
of the solutions that our group
has been trying to come up with and
again a lot of these are very
preliminary this is a very hard problem
that you know will be probably the focus
of
study for years to come to figure out
how to actually tackle some of these
problems
and so the main solution that our group
has been focusing on
is this idea of transparency
with near and to begin with i'm just
going to kind of break down
when i say transparency right this is
kind of this broad
overarching goal but in order to make
transparency real
it takes some you know specific
components
of the transparency to ideally make it
as effective as possible
and right as with much of you know cyber
security or
computer science in general it all
begins with policies
within your and so right these
transparency
um initiatives have to be backed by some
kind of policy within year
ideally right that policy will require
advertisers
to you know make clear to the platforms
in the users some specific set of things
that will then help
those users and other people that are
making use of this transparency better
understand what is being made
transparent in this case
political advertising within your
then once there's some reasonable set of
policies in place
the next thing is right the actual
realization the actual implementation
of this transparency needs to be backed
with some actual technical
implementation by the platforms they
need to build some products
some systems that are able to disclose
the relevant
information and that can write
disseminate
this information both to end users and
to third parties
that want to make use of this
transparency within your
and so then we have this policy we have
the implementationist policy
but then right the security component
you always need some kind of enforcement
because if you have a policy without any
enforcement it's normally not
that worthwhile within your and sorry
the platforms
need to build up some kind of
enforcement where they're able to
both recognize and ideally you know have
in place some penalties
for advertisers that want to try and
evade the transparency requirements
of the platform within your so these are
kind of generically
as we see at the three you know basic
building blocks of transparency
now i'm going to kind of go into a more
concrete
example of how this looks for facebook
in terms
of their political and social issue
transparency that they've built around
their platforms
and to begin with um this they began
doing this
you know after right all of the stuff
with the russians and election
interference came to light
they went to the senate and they
promised transparency
for their political advertising and then
they quickly expanded that to also
include social issue ads as well
within your and facebook's policy has at
least in the u.s
in other countries the rules differ
mandatory disclosure
and transparency of what they deem to be
social issue election and policy ads
and to the credit this is actually a
fairly inclusive policy
that captures a lot of what we feel you
know
is political content
within your and then the next part of
their trans policy policies again
this is mandatory so advertisers are
vetted
and then they're required to provide an
accurate disclosure string
they're naming the entity that paid for
the ad and it has to conform to certain
standards
that facebook has laid out
within here again a fairly reasonable
policy
within your um unfortunately one thing
that facebook did do
is that news publishers did not like
that their ads were being
flagged as political just because you
know they wrote an article
on a political topic within your and so
um facebook right it likes to provide
good customer service
so advertisers and they built out
an exemption for news publishers within
your so this is a loophole in the
transparency where
if a news publisher managed to get on
this exemption list
they don't have to disclose
their ads this transparency system
within you they won't
appear within you and this is a loophole
right that's being actively exploited
as we can see sorry so there's this
whole issue around
what is a legitimate news publisher
within your end right again the news
publishers some of the partisan ones are
pushing the boundaries
as to how partisan they can be and still
get the exemption
so that they don't have to do the
transparency requirements
the other thing with this is right what
is
actually made transparent within your so
the you know the creatives images videos
the text of the ad the disclosure string
of who paid for it
the page that it's connected to are all
made transparent
however the transparency does not
include the actual targeting criteria
that the advertiser set when they
purchase the ad
with an ear now if we look at the
transparency
of facebook's or sorry the
implementation
of facebook's transparency initially
they rolled out a web portal
the web portal this was actually the
motivation for why we started to do this
work in the first place
is that the web portal contained a lot
of data but that data was very hard to
access
basically it was built for a manual
investigation
of ads so if you wanted to ask a simple
question say like who is the you know
the advertiser spending the much money
on political ads on facebook's platforms
that question was very difficult to
answer through this web portal
within here and so um
shortly afterwards we kind of pushed
facebook to implement
an api within your and they implement
this api
unfortunately this api is you know
fairly hard to use
within here um you know they had to roll
it out very quickly
so it's buggy um it wasn't really
designed with the use case
of you know collect all the data in
facebook's
transparency system within here so we've
essentially had to hire
a full-time engineer just to simply get
you know a complete view of the data
from facebook transparency
implementation then after the api they
started to
publish these transparency reports
within you these transparency reports
include the disclosure string how many
ads were purchased by disclosure string
how much that disclosure string spent
within your and they have these monthly
weekly and daily reports
within year facebook only makes
available the most recent reports
in each category they they don't provide
archives
of older reports and analysis
that our team has done
particularly laura did a lot of this
analysis shows that
the spending information is oftentimes
inaccurate
within these reports we went to facebook
with these inaccuracies into their
credit
they they regenerated specific reports
where we found inaccuracies
in these reports however they haven't
made a policy
that when they have inaccuracies to
recompute these reports
so they become accurate within here so
sometimes we find very large
spending irregularities say like four
million dollars appears one day
and then it disappears the next day from
these transparency reports
within your which makes it frustrating
to try and deal with this inaccurate
data
that's being provided the next thing
within your
of their implementation is that they
provide um
spending and impression information but
they bucket it
with an ear and unfortunately sometimes
these buckets are relatively large
facebook has been making these buckets
slightly smaller these days which is
good but still
um a lot of the ads are in that smallest
bucket
essentially zero to ninety nine dollars
being spent within here so most of the
ads are fairly small and so they end up
in that smaller that smallest bucket
within your facebook also provides reach
data
so the states that the impressions were
shown in
and gender and age
demographics of it but again they don't
provide the targeting information
and we've also found through analysis
mullara found
that right that facebook can remove
content
from the ad library so this was
something that if you read their website
they said that they would include all
these ads for seven years
however we found them they've done
several waves of removal
of ads within here so as an example um
in this one year period spanning
2018 to 2019
we estimated that about 8 000 ads were
removed from the ad library composing
about
point two percent of the total within
here so this shows a big need
for some third parties such as ourselves
to archive these ads
in case some of them are later deleted
by facebook
within your the next thing that we
studied
in our research was in terms of the
transparency enforcement
within your and we found that
unfortunately you know
facebook's um enforcement was somewhat
spotty their enforcement happens in two
waves
the first enforcement is when the ad is
placed within there unfortunately we
can't see what ads are rejected
at this phase of the enforcement since
they're never made transparent
but the ones that are accepted and run
on the platform and then later get
caught
are then placed into the transparency
they don't include a disclosure string
for these within here
even if the advertiser had previously
provided one they don't
attach that to the ads that they catch
that weren't properly disclosed
and we found um again in this one year
time period
that about 10 of the ads in the library
were not disclosed at the time of
creation
and later caught
within here um we'll go more into detail
about this later but right these are
just the ones that facebook catches
there's you know as we found there's
ones that facebook doesn't catch
as well the final thing is that based on
our analysis it doesn't appear that
facebook has
penalties at the advertiser level
oftentimes so we saw
advertisers that were able to spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars
running a large number of ads
undisclosed
and they were able to keep running these
ads over and over violating facebook's
transparency policy
and facebook didn't seem to penalize the
advertiser at least in any visible way
that we could see within here so this is
kind of
a rundown of these things within
facebook system
also as part of our research we tried to
propose some improved enforcement
techniques
within ear we developed this algorithm
that could detect what we called kind of
undisclosed coordinating pages
within year and i'll just quickly go
through the algorithm so the algorithm
begins with the um
the page name the disclosure string and
the text
of the ad at the time of this research
we couldn't
programmatically access the images so we
couldn't use those
as part of our algorithm within your
since then facebook has
their credit made the images
programmatically accessible at least
mostly
um and so we take this text and we run
it through the sim
hashing algorithm the idea of the sim
hashing algorithms that produces a hash
where the text you know is similar than
the simhash value
will also be similar within here so it
basically kind of gives us
a rough edit distance between two texts
that will be close if in the sim hash
space
within you and so um you can tune the
simhash
with different values to accept you know
if the texts only have say like
three differences those sim hash to the
same value
within there and so we tuned the simhash
to accept
you know have some tolerance in terms of
differences
and then we found the ones where the sim
hash was the same
with an ear and for the ones with the
sim hash that was the same
these were basically we considered these
to be a cluster of ads
and then we looked at the pages and
disclosure strings
involved in these ads within your and
if we found that you know it was the
same text
but it was being run by different pages
or different disclosure strings we
considered this to be suspicious
within here and we mark these as likely
undisclosed coordinated pages within
your we then manually reviewed these
and i won't have time to really go into
this but we found
a few different you know categories
of these types of undisclosed
coordinating pages
within here probably the most troubling
of these is what we call the inauthentic
communities
where right presumably you know a single
entity what's creating multiple
communities
similar to what laura was saying though
the attacks they might be location-based
identity based
or some of that and then they were
pushing out the same messages
to all those different groups within
there and they were not correctly
disclosing that
they were all from that same entity
within there and they were often times
you know incorrectly disclosing the ads
within there so this was a theoretical
algorithm we ran it
um and ideally facebook would implement
it
if they so choose within your but right
again we don't have control over
facebook's platform
so we tried to use this idea of
clustering
and build kind of a third-party system
that could work
outside of facebook system and we call
this you know with the goal of trying to
help
civil society groups in screening ads
within ear and the the quick idea of the
system is that we
right we cluster ads that are similar
and we essentially call these like ad
campaigns we do it based on the text
and the image of the ad and then we
present the user the system
with you know a single object that
represents that ad campaign
that shows the aggregate of that ad
campaign and so now right instead of
you know sometimes these campaigns have
like thousands of individual ads
that are all part of you know a single
ad campaign within you this makes it
much more
tractable for these civil society groups
to go through
and review these ad campaigns and then
mark the ones that they believe to be
program problematic
for their particular communities so um
we
write we've we've partnered with several
civil society groups
again these civil society groups are
really key to making this work because
right as computer scientists cyber
security experts
we don't oftentimes understand the
threats that are
facing these specific communities within
here and so without that
understanding of what specific threats
there's no way that we could actually
find them
within year but again this domain
expertise of these civil society groups
they right they they have that domain
expertise to know what the threats are
and to identify them
in the system within here so we're
leveraging their domain expertise
through the system within ear having
them flag the ads right now
we don't do a lot with the flagging the
goal in the future
is to use some kind of machine learning
machine learning model to hopefully kind
of recommend or rank
campaigns better so that the ones that
you know our model beliefs
are potentially problematic kind of are
the first ones that they review
within systems this is kind of a future
goal of this ad screening system
within your the next system that we
built was this website
that we call the nyu ad observatory
the goal of this website was to try and
you know organize the transparency
information
and turn it from raw data into actual
ideally this tool is on this website is
focused at journalists
in particular local journalists that
oftentimes can't afford the data science
expertise
or you know the graphic design expertise
to analyze this data within here
and so they can go to this website and
right we we map out all the spending by
state
by state races by sponsors and so they
can go through this data
and this is all to the creative commons
license and so they can simply you know
screenshot
what they're seeing on the website and
include it in their articles if they
wish
within your and this has been highly
successful i think i've lost count
um you know at least 10 20
30 articles by local journalists have
been written
using this data and also more major
you know national news outlets have used
this data as well
to help inform the reporting
however one big limitation of all this
is that we're dependent
on the data again that facebook you know
catches
and makes transparent to their system
and as our you know
analysis and our research showed this
was incomplete
and so we built another tool called ad
observer linear
and the goal of ad observer was to get
an independent source of data
of you know advertising on facebook's
platform in particular political
advertising within you
and so ad observer is a browser plugin
that volunteers can choose to install
and it does not collect any personal
user data within here
all that it collects and the users
essentially donate
to science are the ads that they're
seeing and the targeting
information that facebook isn't making
transparent
within there and so through this
alternative source of data
we can start to find the ads that
facebook never caught
and never made transparent so this is
through our
ad observatory website we've connected
this data source and we can show these
ads like this nra ad this joe biden ad
that facebook did not catch and make
transparent within the system so this
exposes
at least some of the ads that facebook
is missing
within their system and again we also
get the targeting information so that we
can use this to enrich our understanding
of advertising
as well so these are all you know
preliminary
steps towards transparency a lot of this
is focused at facebook
ideally we can expand this to other
platforms like youtube
and things like that in the future with
a near and we can keep building on and
keep experimenting
and learning how to make transparency
more useful to all these different
stakeholders
and the most challenging one is end
users within your we haven't really
addressed that one
much yet
um this is kind of we consider this to
be more of a short-term
solution with an ear ideally there's
some more longer-term solutions
a lot of these might require more of a
redesign
of these systems within year one of the
ideas that we have
is right facebook and other platforms
have decided that you know their
customers
are always right within here
and so um ideally they will
learn about the problems that this kind
of mindset policy creates
and they will you know make the decision
or perhaps regulation will step in and
make the decision that
you know some ads should not be run in
the system if
you know of the particular type that
laura was showing before
if right they're factually incorrect or
if they're
you know trying to undermine the
democratic process as a whole
within here um ideally the platforms
could you know um allow the users more
control
over the contents that they see within
their platform
it's all right if advertisers say you
know or excuse me users
don't want to see any ads or particular
types say like conspiracy theory ads
or organic content they can simply just
say to
the platforms like facebook do not show
me anything that you suspect
is conspiracy theory related within you
and the same can go maybe you know they
don't like cats
and so they say do not show me any cat
content within there although who
doesn't like caps
um and then right again the platform can
kind of
do better prioritization of things
perhaps
you know to not um
advantage extreme political content as
much as it's currently advantaged
on their platform with linear
and so with that that's pretty much um
the solutions that we're
currently exploring in the ones that we
think should be explored
in the future it's an is an amazing
amount of work you guys have been doing
i'm uh
i'm really impressed uh
what do you do about what do you do
about natural language though that's
that's
that's of course uh difficult you're
working with
text and and photographs
uh the photographs you can do a little
bit of uh
uh image analysis on but not much
that's really critical we do a lot of
textual analysis
yeah so um one of the things that we do
as part of how we
first we cluster and then organize
information for screening system users
to do
is we classify all ads by their topic so
in order to do that
we obviously have to analyze the text
in addition to that we also extract
named entities
because we find that that can also
provide signal for both
understanding topics and also
understanding um
particular risk factors so um
all ads we have an analysis pipeline
that all ads go through
where we you know it's a fair we do we
we do some fairly standard natural
language processing uh
approaches where we you know we evaluate
the text we pull out named entities
um we do that topic classification we
also use the text to
um we have a politicalness it's actually
a regression model
um with a with a hard cut off um
that we use for various things but yeah
i mean fundamentally what we're doing is
trying to understand the content
of ads in order to do some of these
other
risk evaluations and um and just
groupings
and you you also cluster ads
that's the thing that's most interesting
is that you you're actually
clustering what will you only within the
facebook platform you don't try to
correlate against uh ads on twitter or
instagram or something like that we're
actually planning on doing that next
so i think this year we really focused
on
facebook because they are certainly the
800 pound gorilla
in online disinformation but we think
that
um as as both david and i alluded to
these are cross-platform problems
and the most successful campaigns do
exist
in in multiple spaces so we think that
the next thing we need to tackle
is taking some of the algorithms we've
developed here and applying them
you know to cross-platform content
amazing amazing piece of work um
and you know it it applies it applies
much more broadly than just the
the ad space i as we were talking before
we started here we're talking about
the the news space which uh is
in many ways uh very similar to the ad
space and it's difficult to
differentiate the two sometimes
and it's going to be very difficult to
um well i don't know the internet seems
to
die on truth these days because you
don't really know what's real and what's
not
uh later later on today i'm i'm uh
talking with
an artist in palo alto who makes uh
videos of um people in
high places of like the the
ceo at uh facebook uh saying things that
they would never say but doing it in a
way where
it is um transparent and obvious that
it's
he's saying it and it's not it's a it's
a fake
so you know the presence of fakes
everywhere is getting to be
uh make uh just simply navigating
uh transparently and difficult i mean
transparency is
place to start but it's not going to be
enough
um we're going to have to have better
cross-checking in
in different ways but anyhow
just re i really impressed i think i
think you've done very very interesting
work
and um you know it's uh unfortunate that
it's uh
it has to be done but it's getting to be
uh getting to be the uh
the requirement for uh for survival in
our age
do you think there's a reasonable future
for the internet
the um if you if you
if you look at some of the the groups in
europe and
and in australia and such uh they're
people who are adamant against any
invasion of
privacy adamant against the use of
cryptography
how to get adamant in many ways against
privacy as
in the whole um
i'm very optimistic for the future i you
know i do think that
you know so one of the problems that i
think our community is having with this
particular problem
is there is a real struggle with
some of the some of the core principles
that i think are
are really intrinsic to the internet
like free speech like freedom of
expression
and you know what we're running up
against is
things like q and on where you know
it's it's i i i i'm
just as much in favor of free speech and
free expression as as
as most other people are but that is a
but q anon is a is a pattern of belief
that has gotten people killed and i
think that
there's a there's a place where you know
when you
want to put principles into practice you
need to do it with an element of common
sense
and so you know and that's why we really
try to try to lay out things like you
know false beliefs with a profit motive
with some kind of
you know with other false things because
any one of these things in isolation
aren't necessarily harmful but i think
you know
i think we can say like look there's
there's plenty of there's plenty of
fiction out there that nobody gets hurt
but we can also we can also say look we
can also have some common sense and draw
some lines
where people will get hurt
i think you're right and go to it
thank you very much and we appreciate
your your time and effort
and uh i wish you the very best in the
in your future research
and uh we certainly will keep in touch
thanks so much